Today I want to talk about the benefits
of a non-rules-based program of language
learning and language instruction.
The last video I made, I talked
about this book, "The Mind Within
the Net" by Manfred Spitzer, where
he talks about how the brain learns.
And I drew some conclusions from
that, conclusions as to how the brain
learns, how the brain—based on
being bombarded with events, or with
words, or with structures, exposure
to the language, input—gradually
the brain develops its own rules
about how the language works.
In other words, those
rules cannot be instructed.
The rules are developed naturally
by the brain. And I talked about
how the hippocampus, which is the
short-term and medium-term memory,
tries to get access to as many,
say, events or words or facts or things
of that nature that it holds onto
for a short period of time and then
gradually pumps it into the cortex.
Now, there are some very important
benefits from this non-rules-based
language learning approach.
The first one is
that we shouldn't doubt ourselves.
I talked about how [for] children at play, it's
an opportunity for them to experiment
in a relatively safe environment.
There can be no catastrophic event.
It's not like going hunting in the old
days with their parents where they might
cause a major catastrophe to happen.
It's safe, experiment,
interact with people.
Gradually, through this
experience, acquiring knowledge.
So that's how we learn languages.
We learn languages through being
exposed, much like the child at play.
In fact, we should be
like the child at play.
So we are listening, we are
reading, and we are speaking.
And when we are speaking, we shouldn't
doubt ourselves.
We shouldn't try to remember a rule.
"Is this correct?"
We should rely more on the natural process
of whatever the cortex or the long-term
acquisition of ability, knowledge, longer-
term knowledge, whatever state it is at.
And whether what you retrieve
at this time is right or wrong,
none of that should matter.
You should just go with your instinct.
Don't second guess yourself anymore
than the child at play is going to
second guess him- or herself.
Just go with it.
I think we can
just rely on the process.
It doesn't really matter if you make
a mistake. You aren't going to do better
by trying to refer to what Krashen
talks about as the affective filter.
In other words, second guessing
yourself based on some rule.
Just rely on whatever comes out.
Because it's a gradual process of
learning and you just have to go with
whatever you got. And you'll probably
be better that way than if you
self-consciously try to refer to a rule.
So don't doubt yourself.
The second thing that I think is very
beneficial from this understanding of
how language learning works is that
we should focus on being active. In
other words, rather than worrying about
what we have achieved in the language.
And I think this message goes as much to
the learners who are always hoping that
they would be better than they are, as
well as the teachers who want to teach
and
test and show X points out of 10.
The teacher can't teach you the rule.
Testing you on the rule doesn't matter.
You have to just rely on staying so
active that there are enough language
events, words, sounds, sentences,
exposure to the language coming at
you. And that the hippocampus then,
if we take that model, is then passing
on to the longer-term cortex area to
develop your skill in the language.
As long as you keep doing that, the more
active you are, the more things are being
pushed into your cortex in the sort of
longer-term processing area, the better.
So all you need to worry about is not how
well you've done on the last test or how
well you're going to do on the next test.
You just have to keep active.
So that simplifies the task at hand.
So if you can go out and find interesting
things to do in the language or vary
between interesting but difficult texts
and easier texts where there's perhaps
more repetition of familiar words.
You keep doing this kind of stuff,
pumping it into your cortex.
Eventually you're going to
improve. But you improve slowly.
The third thing that's beneficial about
understanding this way of learning
is something that I have observed on
many occasions, and that is that if you
have had enough activity in the language,
have done enough listening and reading,
have read books and so forth, if you
then leave the language for a while, when
you go back to it, because everything
is stored in your long-term memory.
All of that stuff is still
there somewhere in the cortex.
You may not be able to retrieve it
right away, but as you reactivate the
language, you reactivate all of these
associations that were part of how you
acquired the words. Associations with
sounds, with context, with similar
words or different words, or
whatever those associations were.
There's this network of associations
that connect all these words in some way.
And so even if you leave the language,
if you've got it to a sufficient
level, you don't have to worry.
And in fact, as I have said, I have
often found that when I go back to
a language that I have left, in what
I termed a period of "benign neglect"
of course, in the short term, I
forget certain words. But in the
long-term, I am better than ever.
So I am better today in even those
languages that I speak quite well,
but which I didn't spend much
time on because I was learning
new languages. But when I go back to
my Japanese, or my Chinese, or my French,
or my Spanish, I'm actually better
now than I was before because all of
that activity somehow has improved
my ability to retrieve the language,
use the language in ways that I don't
fully understand. But I am convinced
if we take the position that we
are not going to learn rules and
extrapolate from rules, but instead
we're going to expose ourselves to as
much of the language as possible,
hopefully in interesting contexts,
but as long as we're exposed all the time
and we're not doubting ourselves when we
use the language, we're like the child at
play, and we stay as active as we possibly
can, pumping stuff into our cortex,
then after an absence and we go back
to that language, we're going to find
that we are at least as good as
we ever were, and possibly better.
So there's lots of advantages
to taking this non-rules-based
approach to language learning.